sollen die deutsche zögerlichkeit
annehmen wir die kommentare aus youtube
und facebook noch dazu simon kürzer
geschrieben und ich denke das sind zwei
dies gut auf einen punkt bringen
einerseits so sehr die ukraine auch im
recht ist sie werden diesen krieg nie
gewinnen können waffenlieferungen
verlängern nur das leid und erhöhen die
brutalität dieses krieges und
andererseits schreibt jemand mit dem
kürzel s p nur zögerlichen lieferungen
führen zu mehr toten wenn schneller mehr
geliefert würde würde putin schneller zu
verhandlungen gezwungen das sind glaube
ich die beiden sichtweisen zwischen
denen man gerade sich bewegt
sondern interessante zusammenstellung
die sie gerade gewählt haben einfach aus
dem grunde weil ich persönlich der
auffassung bin dass die freiheit der
demokratische staaten europas derzeit in
der ukraine verteidigt wird das heißt
wenn jemand sagt waffenlieferung
verlängern so den krieg sagte damit in
direkter weise ausdruck eines soll auf
geben und dann werden wir sehen wie die
folgen aussehen die dadurch entstehen
dann geht es weiter nach transnistrien
dann geht es weiter nach moldau dann
willkommen möglicherweise lust darauf
auch auf andere an anderen stellen in
europa anzugreifen von daher dass diese
lösung für mich keine lösung sondern die
aufgabe und damit müssen wir pushen und
seiner politik in jeder beziehung recht
geben da ist die andere auffassung
geäußert worden ist
selbst waffenlieferungen alston
durchgeführt werden müssen müssen und
ich bin mal das beispiel der norweger
aus den jüngsten tagen die artillerie
geschütze in die ukraine geliefert haben
ohne lange vorher darüber zu reden aber
die geschützte sind bereits da das halte
ich dann für die bessere lösung und wir
müssen wirklich aus der zeitachse gucken
wir geben glaube ich morgen inters
fünften tag dieses krieges rein und wir
hätten eigentlich vor 90 tagen
entscheiden sollten die waffen zu
liefern dann wären sie schon da und die
42-tägige ausbildung für die afghanische
soldaten an der panzerhaubitze
2000 lehrer seit 50 tagen abgeschlossen
marseille das sind dimensionen über die
man sich klar werden muss und die eine
wahnsinnige rolle in der weiteren
unterstützung der ukraine spielen und
wir müssen uns im klaren sein erstes
sieht der konflikt ist ich heute oder
morgen zu ende sondern wird monate oder
länger dauern
ist die erste feststellungen sie die
zweite vorstellung steven wie die
ukraine nicht unterstützen hast du
kleines verloren und wir haben es gehört
es geht wirklich um tage und es geht
momentan um einen stellungskrieg so muss
man es wohl nennen bei diesen zwillings
stellten
die aussage zu treffen mit dem risiko
dabei lasst doch autokratische kräfte
und weitere zivilpersonen in kritische
zivilisten durch die russischen soldaten
eingeschlossen werden können
malachowski fragt via facebook warum
wird immer auf deutschland eingeschlagen
weil keine waffen geliefert werden sind
wir die einzigen die so was haben die eu
hat fast 30 ländern nur mal so gefragt
haben sie ja vorhin schon ein land
genannt aber insgesamt wenn man mal auf
die waffenlieferung wer wieviel wann
geliefert hat wie steht es da aus ihrer
sicht
also erstens ich musste jetzt ein
bisschen korrigieren norwegen gehört
nicht zur eu sei nato land welches dort
unterstützt hat ich glaube aber dass
insgesamt bei den waffenlieferungen der
der gouverneur hat vorhin auch einige
länder genannt aus dem unmittelbaren
umfeld die bereits geliefert haben dass
wir bei den waffenlieferungen was die
geschwindigkeit der waffenlieferungen
angeht ziemlich weit hinten anstehen ob
das jetzt die innenpolitische
parteipolitische gründe sind oder aus
politische gründe sind möchte ich jetzt
nicht untersuchen ich sage das in aller
deutlichkeit das muss vielleicht zu
einem späteren zeitpunkt noch einmal
aufbereitet werden jede waffe die nicht
kommt schale der ukraine jede waffe die
zu spät geliefert wird nutzt er um
gerade nicht mehr von daher gehöre ich
mit zu denen und das sage ich in aller
deutlichkeit die sagen wir haben zeit
verloren und wir müssen sehen dass wir
diese zeit zumindest in teilen durch die
unterstützung der ukraine zurückgewinnen
kommen wir auf die strategie zu sprechen
präsident selensky wir haben zu einem
beitrag gehört waren vor einem dammbruch
wenn der dom das feld fällt dann die
ganze ukraine ist das zutreffend aus
ihrer sicht
also präsident selensky baut in dieser
situation ich sag das mal vorsichtig
sicherlich einen damm auf einen dann
auch auf um die entsprechende
unterstützung aus dem westen weiterhin
zu bekommen also wenn der don was
tatsächlich ganz feld spricht die region
luhansk und jetzt ist der krieg in der
ukraine nicht zu ende er geht weiter man
konnte aus meldungen der letzten tage
konnte man entnehmen dass beispielsweise
wörtliche raumgewinne im raum saison
durch die ukrainischen soldaten erzielt
worden sind und die ukraine wird an der
stelle nicht aufgeben sondern der krieg
geht weiter und muss dann möglicherweise
an anderen stellen weiter und intensiver
fortgesetzt werden aber wir müssen uns
darüber im klaren sein dass eine
derartige fortsetzung natürlich auch
weitere zerstörungen in der ukraine
bedeuten weitere hohe verluste bei den
soldaten weitere hohe verluste vor allem
aber auch beim ziel der zivilbevölkerung
und alles was da vermieden werden kann
ist positiv wenn die ukraine diese
position hält und möglicherweise zu
einem späteren zeitpunkt mit der
unterstützung der westlichen staaten
dann auch gelände zurück erzielt
verbessert sich seine strategische
situation erkennen dass einer position
der schwäche nicht in verhandlungen mit
russland eintreten oder mit sogar mit
ladepunkten eintreten weil er dann so
eine verhandlungsziele die er sich
selber gesetzt hat nicht erreichen wird
und das macht die sache dann deutlich
schwieriger die lage ist sowieso relativ
unübersichtlich werden von die karte mal
eingeblendet viele städte eng zusammen
da geht es dann nicht nur um
strategische ausrichtungen sondern
natürlich auch wir haben es vor einem
interview mit dem gouverneur gehört
welche staat überhaupt eingenommen wurde
und in welcher form
diese art stellungskrieg mit den hohen
verlusten von denen sie sprachen und wir
haben noch weitere bilder die wir jetzt
an der stelle zeigen können wie kann man
das verhindern oder ist jetzt der
zeitpunkt gekommen zu sagen da muss
schluss sein an der stelle diese form
von diesem krieg ist jetzt zu dramatisch
für die zivilbevölkerung täter oder gibt
es überhaupt irgendjemand der darauf
rücksicht nimmt
stefanski was wir sagen ist nach meinem
kenntnisstand und so wie ich die lage
einschätze in den ohren von vladimir
punkten und damit auch der handel
russischen militärs ich sag das mal
vorsichtig völlig um
wir müssen versuchen hier tatsachen zu
schaffen dh die russen anzuhalten und
der gouverneur hat gerade sehr gute
argumente dazu gebracht die ich auch
wirklich nur noch mal verstärken kann er
sprach von der weitreichenden artillerie
wir müssen versuchen zu verhindern dass
die russische artillerie die russen mit
ihren raketenwerfern weit in das land
hinein schießen können hohe verluste bei
der bevölkerung an der infrastruktur
verursachen und das kann man nur dann
die ukraine nur dann erreichen wenn sie
mit dem zur verfügung gestellten
waffensystem in der lage ist die
stellung der russischen artillerie zu
bekämpfen und damit im prinzip den
beschuss von der seite von der
russischen seite her zu beenden das
heißt es geht darum die abstellung der
russen
setzten kanonen oder raketenwerfer
aufzuklären und in diese stellung hinein
zu feuer so dass die russen gezwungen
werden sich aus diese stellung
zurückzuziehen oder mit präzisionswaffen
wie beispielsweise ja sonst aber bis zu
2000 raketenwerfer auch dem den die
amerikaner liefern dafür zu sorgen dass
diese akteure auf große entfernung
vernichtet wird erst dann wird sich
dieses kriegs bild ändern und dann
möglicherweise so hoffe ich jedenfalls
zum vorteil der ukraine ausschlagen
wobei ich dann auch wieder die
kampfmoral der ukrainischen soldaten
bezogen möchte die wirklich
hervorragendes bisher geleistet haben
und sicherlich auch weiter leisten
werden glauben sie denn dass putin
zufrieden sein wird wenn er den osten
der ukraine erobert hat wenn die
russische armee die auch zum teil jetzt
schon im süden des landes seine macht
unter beweis gestellt hat
wer steht pansky sie fragen nicht wieder
ein bisschen nach der berühmten
glaskugel das war versuchen dort in
diese richtung einfach eine trockene
analyse zu machen und trockene analyse
beginnt am 17 dezember nämlich an dem
zeitpunkt wo putin seine ziele für die
ukraine operation im prinzip bekannt
gegeben hat und wo er den westen
versucht hat unter druck zu setzen in
bestimmten bereichen einzulenken dass
eines dieser strategischen ziele ist die
einnahme der gesamten ukraine
das ablösen der derzeitigen ukrainische
regierung die ja mit den begriffen die
faschisten und rassisten und drogen
belegt hat und ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass er von sich aus diese
ziele auf gibt er sei denn es sei denn
er wird durchaus mittel dazu gezwungen
genau an der stelle stehen wir jetzt und
über diese situation diskutieren wir
wenn er eine chance sieht weiter vor zu
marschieren später tf einzunehmen
durchzumarschieren ist nach odessa ist
nach transnistrien vorzudringen wenn er
diese chance sieht so etwas machen da
habe ich überhaupt aufgrund seiner
bisherigen vorgehensweise überhaupt
keine zweifel gibt es denn dann
überhaupt einen strategischen zeitpunkt
um zu verhandeln
ich habe das gerade schon mal ganz kurz
angedeutet um meinen worten sie brauchen
militärische erfolge für die ukrainische
streitkräfte so dass putin oder in
russland zweifel auftreten ob sie ihre
eigenen strategischen ziele oder auch
operativen ziele erreichen erst dann
machen verhandlungen sind aus einer
position der schwäche in einer
verhandlung reinzugehen ist in meinen
augen unzweckmäßig wir würden dann aus
einer position der schwäche in
verhandlung reingehen zu einer situation
kommen die dann das was der
bundeskanzler ein diktat frieden genannt
hat für die russen möglicherweise
ermöglichen würden und das kann nicht
unser interesse soll jenseits der
glaskugel wer ist denn derjenige der aus
ihrer sicht dem teufelskreis in dem wir
momentan sind durchbrechen kann und wie
letztendlich punkt ihn selber putin muss
auf irgendeine weise zu der erkenntnis
gebracht werden dass er in der ukraine
keine militärischen folge mehr ringen
kann das damit seine strategischen ziele
in frage gestellt werden und ich jetzt
muss ich aber schon wieder von hoffnung
reden und ich hoffe dass dann in der
ukraine in den russischen gehirn auch
bei putin selber ein denkprozess
einsetzt hat möglicherweise zu dem
ergebnis kommen könnte das alles was
danach kommt dann für die russen eine
verschlechterung bedeuten würde und dann
könnte man vielleicht darüber die
bereitschaft erreichen sich an den
verhandlungstisch zu rechnen zu setzen
wir sollten vielleicht auch im westen
nicht so viel über verhandlungen reden
so dass vielleicht mehr entschlossenheit
zeigen diesen krieg weiter zu
unterstützen zugunsten der ukraine denn
schon das signalisieren von
verhandlungsbereitschaft wird zweitens
putin dass solche geschichte der letzten
monate der letzten wochen als westliche
schwäche ausgewählt und wenn er auf
diese art und weise auch wegen
unterschiedlicher politischer äußerungen
beispielsweise der europäische staaten
in der lage ist einen keil zwischen die
europäer zu treiben dann hat er den
ersten schritt gemacht um praktisch zum
eigenen erfolg zu kommen und das ist
etwas was wir nicht zulassen dürfen wir
reden über ein land ein selbstständiges
land mit eigenem territorium das geht so
nicht weiter
befragt wie youtube rams wie definieren
sie denn die kriegsziele der ukraine
also wenn mein kenntnisstand richtig ist
obwohl es ja auch sehr unterschiedliche
nachrichten gegeben hat mal hat man
zuletzt zugesagt da würde sich dann wenn
der donnersberg währungen die grimberg
wäre damit zufrieden geben wenn ich die
information der letzten tage detailliert
und genau bewährte da hat die ukraine
die absicht die integrität ihres
territoriums so wieder herzustellen wie
sie vor 2014 vor der annektierung der
krim gewesen ist und das ist auch ein
legitimes kriegsziel für die ukraine und
damit auch für den präsidenten zu lenski
und ich wiederhole meine aussage und
dabei sollten wir die ukraine
unterstützen die freiheit europas wird
in der ukraine verteidigt darüber müssen
wir uns im klaren sollen
abschließend es macht einen unterschied
ob man sagt die ukraine darf den krieg
nicht verlieren oder sie muss ihn
gewinnen die politik hat ihre sicht der
dinge welche haben sie
also ich bleibe bei der aussage die ich
gerade gemacht habe unsere unterstützung
muss dahin gehen dass es zumindest der
erste schritt dass wir die ukraine so
stark befähige mit unserer unterstützung
die auch lange dauern kann laut lange
dauern wird dass wir die ukraine
befähigen erfolge in diesen in dieser
schlacht in diesem kampf zu haben die
möglicherweise herrn putin zum
nachdenken bringen das ist der erste
schritt sollte er darauf nicht reagieren
kann das ziel auch von unserer seite her
nur sein die ukraine durch den
entsprechenden einsatz der ukrainischen
soldaten mit unserer unterstützung zu
befähigen dass sie ihre territorialen
grenzen von vor annektierung der krim
wiederherstellen kann